now there's been a major flare up in
violence between Armenia and aeran in
the disputed nagorno kabak region
armenia's defense Ministry spokesman
tweeted out these images apparently
showing azer bani tanks being destroyed
aeran says it's launched a large counter
offensive along the front line the
region has declared martial law and the
mobilization of its male population
nagoro kabak is internationally
recognized as part of aeran but it's
control by Armenian forces Robin
Forester Walker is monitoring
developments from tii in Georgia he
joins us on the phone from there so
let's start with this General
mobilization going on in nagoro kabak
it's just been announced I guess that's
a sign that things are not calming
down no Sammy it doesn't look that way
at all I've been in touch with both
foreign ministries of aaban and Armenia
and as you were saying both sides
accusing the other of starting
which of course uh is the typical um
statements that you hear um so it's very
difficult to get a clear picture but uh
what the aaries are saying is that um
the
Armenians uh began uh shelling civilian
positions and Military positions on
their front line on their side of the
front line of
uh of the military area um that we're
talking about now which is neor caraba
and that civilians were injured and two
as military personnel killed um and what
the Armenians are saying is that the
aaries launched a fullscale attack on
their positions um including the
regional Capital
stepanakert uh which is a very
significant development because
stepanakert uh was not targeted uh
during the the last time there was a a
major conflict there the 4 day conflict
in 20 uh 2016 I believe um we also saw
violence earlier this year but that was
not in the gner carak area this
contested area so the fact that stanaker
has been targeted really um UPS the anti
so to speak um the aaries have not
confirmed whether or not they they did
strike stanaker but that is that is a
very serious cause for concern um and as
you showing there the Armenians um you
know quick to use um military pictures
um of the the the the attacks that
they've been able to um make on the aeri
side and inflicting um damage to AAR
equipment um the areas have in the past
used um unmanned drones to carry out
missile strikes um they have significant
military hardware in fact they have um
spent a very large amount of their
budget on U building up their Armed
Forces but the Armenians also are well
fortified uh uh their positions they're
the ones who control carabat um and so
the potential for for you know serious
injuries in as because this area is also
there are civilian populations on both
sides so potential for for more serious
damage to civilian infrastructure and
civilian positions um is is always there
and and this is very worrying to see
this happening right now well that
Segways into my next question uh for you
Robin because in the past when we've
seen conflict it it has sparked uh
massive casualties in the civilian
population an exodus of people leaving
the region what is the humanitarian
situation well um Neo caraba is um is
populated uh with civilians um the
stanaker the regional capital is quite a
large Town um uh and um there are also a
number of villages um that are sort of
quite quite strung out uh along the the
sort of lowlands as well of this area
that Armenia controls um and they tend
to be kind of mixed in with with
military positions um because of the
fact that this area has been you know a
a regional conflict zone for so many
years um and on the aeri side too these
are these are farming Villages um mixed
in with the front lines um uh you know
you're never far from from civilian
positions that can be easily hit of
course because the shelling um you know
isn't necessarily that accurate um
although when we had a a flare up back
in July this year the emphasis um that
both sides were trying to portray this
was all about targeted um you know use
of of of of of of very sophisticated
weapons um often on the in iser's case
these are Israeli built drones um that
are capable of of targeting very
specific uh places and they've shown a
lot of videos of of military
installations being hit but always the
potential for a civilian uh casualties
is is huge and um it's very concerning
to see that civilian positions including
stepen to being struck now if that is
the case all right thanks so much Robin
for your Walker there